good afternoon Michael malice here let
that be your welcome for the next two
hours we are live here in sunny
Milwaukee where it is hotter than JFK's
house I am here to be delighted to be
hosting Dave rubin's return to the
internet you have been off the internet
for all of August yes uh this has been a
show you do every year when you go back
on the air I am sitting in the same
chair that Glenn Beck Larry Elder Ben
Shapiro and Michael Nelson farted in I'm
adding my own set to that and we're
going to be filling you in on what
happened over the last month I have
literally I just want to be very very
clear about this as you know but I want
everyone to know this watch this I have
literally no idea what's going on in the
world we're at the Republican debate
right now and everyone's coming up to me
at the hotel and at the airport Diva
it's crazy it's crayon I'm just like
don't talk to me don't tell me anything
I have no idea uh I will tell you one I
do have one thing that I think maybe
happen do you want to just get that out
right up absolutely by contextual clue I
do think a celebrity who I like died
we're gonna open up the two celebrity
deaths okay hold that thought so I'll
hold that tell that thought can I just
say one other thing before we begin and
then this is your program to take us
wherever you want to go uh I have been
in a Mexican rainforest for the last two
weeks amongst the monkeys and the
silence and the rain and doing
absolutely nothing I forgot my uh wallet
yesterday going to the airport because I
just haven't had any wallets or phones
or anything forgot my belt today which
I'm wearing a Target belt right now you
use our secret code and say don't you
know who I am well two guys recognize me
at TSA but they still they apparently
they don't take a random guy saying oh
yeah that's Dave Rubin to let you
through I had to be taken into Homeland
Security and anyway I made it to
Milwaukee I don't even know who's here I
try I do not know I don't know if Trump
is coming I have no idea what's going on
enlighten me Michael I assume everything
got better in the world right yeah I
have to tell you I'm you're nervous
doing this show right now okay for you
because are you there's a lot of terms
that people use in political discourse
that are real meaning racism everything
racism means I don't like it I'm a
racist a degenerate yeah that means I
don't like it are you familiar with the
term long con
long time the long con no that's when
you work with someone and build up your
confidence with them in a rapport so
that it pays off in the end so now you
have me biggest trolls for two hours
running your show oh my here's what
we're gonna open with okay there are
eight candidates at the debate tonight
okay I am and you know you and I are
both Political Animals yeah I'm familiar
with seven of them
let's see if you can guess who those
eight are and it shouldn't be too hard
to guess those seven out of eight okay
so I'll remove Trump for just a second
so DeSantis Ricky Vivek uh well I did
not know he was here but I'm very
excited to see that Larry Elder is here
because he's across the street he's here
because he's not in there he did not
make the debate he didn't make it ah I
saw my damn damn
uh well that's upsetting uh I'm gonna
guess that Suarez snuck his way in who
uh Francis Suarez mayor of Miami all
right so wait I said I said you got
three of them so far DeSantis Nikki
tell me ASA Hutchinson
congrats buddy he didn't retire after
that Tucker incident that was like one
of the last things that I saw sign in
for a book deal I mean that's hilarious
so okay he's here uh Chris Christie yes
sir so that's five you know uh do you
know what Chris Christie's nickname was
trending on Twitter I'm not making this
up
Krispy Kreme
that's funny no I didn't I'm serious
that's not totally horrible all right so
I'm missing two now one of them may be
very obviously well so then well so
Trump may be one obviously but I'm just
gonna put that aside for a second I'm
missing an obvious one who did I forget
out of these people hold on hold on who
else is running for president
God I've been out of it for a while can
I get a hint uh who's the vice president
oh he's running too
granted him so nope the robot pretending
to be Pence okay and then I guess number
seven is either Trump but if it's not
Trump let me just think for one sec who
else it might be
it's the diversity hire of the
Republican party it's the diversity hire
of the Republican Party
they gotta they gotta oh Tim Scott Yeah
Yeah Tim Scott I forgot about him too
man I've been out of it so Trump's not
here hold on he's number eight
Doug is his name Doug burgram who is the
governor of North Dakota wasn't he a
pitcher for the Brewers
in the Starbucks this morning I've been
told to tell you this I did yes oh yeah
that guy who said hi to me and he is in
the ER uh because he has some basketball
accident yesterday apparently wait
there's a question if he's going to be
there tonight wait this guy Doug who's
running for president who made it in
over Larry Elder yes had a basketball
accident yesterday and is now not
showing up here today possibly not
showing up
because Doug burgram is really the guy
whoever wants to see Doug Burger I
wouldn't mind playing basketball
you sent him to the hospital literally
wow all right so oh so Trump's not here
so that's the so the big here was the
here was the criteria the Republicans
said you have to have certain a certain
number of donors 40 000 donors at least
a dollar amount of money yeah uh and
also have a certain percent in the polls
I think one percent yeah but you also
have to sign a loyalty oath which Trump
refused to do
here's the other thing wow this time
he's way ahead in all the polls he's not
that's a strategy for him it's not a
complete crazy one uh it's interesting
that Chris Christie who has been very
very vocally anti-trump I'm sure that
happened before you left he signed that
loyalty pledge I don't think this lawyer
The Pledge is going to hold any water
because no it does it doesn't mean
anything because he's a legally binding
documents you've changed your mind
pursuing you so we're gonna start with
that's what Trump is not here Trump is
not here wow but there is wow there is
Trump news happening today and tomorrow
we don't want to get you no no no no
Dave now I'm like you don't understand
I'm pissed about the Larry Elder thing
you see standing right over there yeah
well that's why he's standing over there
and I'm there let's see if Larry can
come up and wave to the people or
something yeah let me run my show all
right run your show so we're gonna start
with the deaths uh someone who's very
famous and can I tell you the one that I
think maybe got it right so I think
maybe and it's for people of our age
with our uh Pee-wee Herman died TV
Herman died I know how they buried him
in a movie theater no no not a joke for
me somewhere in a blue Goldberg machine
no no they put the body in the table and
all the pallbearers are going to rub the
body out until temptation
you know how I kind of got so that was
the only thing that I thought I got a
contextual clue on because did that
happen very early in the month July 31st
yeah so I'm like August 1st or 2nd I
didn't have a phone anymore and I didn't
have any social media or anything but I
turned on Apple TV just to turn on
Netflix or whatever and peewee's big
adventure was the number one thing on
there and then like a few days later I
went into I think HBO Max and they had
people on big top peewee and another
Peewee thing and I was like either he
got caught in the theater again doing
his thing or he's dead so Ah that's he
was a legend really bad Peewee news that
would might make you not like him as
much when I heard this it broke my heart
do you want to hear it oh no do you want
to hear it or do you not want to hear it
this has nothing to do with his death
this is let's show but yeah so Peewee
remember that and someone else I don't
know the other one so the other person
you don't know this guy his name is
Donovan cryptaddy on Twitter he was a
young up and coming comedian his album
came out in July uh we're gonna have a
little clip from him we're gonna play
right now so for some weird reason I
keep getting kind of close to people
breaking out being like oh clear did you
did this person winning Awards and
and swimming it's up man what do
you think
I'm just like I mean
all right Marty McBride his mouth wants
to swim let her swim Dude down
there like no dude that's Leah Thompson
Leah Thomas it's called Sports
Illustrated comedian Edition his first
album he was in a wheelchair disabled
comedian very very funny he had DM me to
do the show I never applied to him and
now he's gone what happened what
happened uh he had a lifelong disability
so you know he was young and you know so
it's very unfortunate if I just wanted
to give him a shout out because he was a
great kid who was a very very funny dark
humor which I very much enjoy yeah okay
uh news with Elizabeth not the white
list of the black lizzo okay
um I basically know she's just a very
very large woman well her dancers have
sued her
uh citing sexual harassment including
taking them to like red light districts
and having them doing appropriate things
but they also sued her for fat shaming
them
and I'm going to quote my buddy comedian
Kurt Metzger who said if lizzo's fat
shaming you maybe there's a problem wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait lizzo
the giant woman that giant woman who
wears the bikinis he dances around or
whatever
she fat shamed somebody else her dancers
or her dancers fatter than her well
how's that possible
no they are not fatter than her I'm very
confused by this yeah so this is a
lawsuit that's going on wow yeah
so here's some other stuff uh this one
you may have seen coming this is like a
big one because this is like a series of
dominoes August 1st okay uh in DC yeah a
Federal grand jury indicted president
Trump over alleged efforts to overturn
the election I'm shocked and appalled
yeah yeah are you sure right no another
one of these things you know when I when
I went off the grid last year was the
Mar-A-Lago raid and then when I came
back actually and Larry Elder was the
was the guest house the marlago raid I
think was like the first week of August
right and then I came back he tells me
about the whole thing and I was like you
know nothing's gonna happen with this
like well so what what's going on now
another indictment we're going to do
this in chronological order yeah okay so
that was a kind of a very big one um and
this is in DC and obviously with the DC
jury it's going to be very tough for any
Republican including president Trump so
he's got the federal case he's now got
the decent case the New York okay let's
do them all in order yeah
um August 2nd Justin Trudeau uh
self-identified heterosexual Justin
Trudeau has announced his separation
from his wife
I mean he's gay as a fruitcake right
like that guy is gayer than a picnic
basket I'm giving you some good Sophia
petrilla references here right sure or
he's a woman or what he's good yeah uh
by the way just for the listening no
straight guy wears those socks you don't
even wear those socks that's true yeah
look you have very standard black guys
just like me so fun fact for Halloween
this year you can wear black face just
say you're dressed as Justin Trudeau
wow so he's getting div well can you
imagine any any human being wanting to
spend any time with him as Jordan
Peterson always says the Man simply
cannot say one hold on but one word of
Truth he can't say one sentence you'd
have to be with your husband right
you're probably a politician you stay
married right you just you're basically
sucking the power teat so this one I
thought was really interesting that uh
Rhonda sand this is like I think
politics at its best because a lot of
you know as you and I both discussed
often American has become much more
divided and people are talking past each
other people talking they're in bubbles
uh Ron DeSantis and Gavin Newsom agreed
to debate because there really is this
idea in America of like do you want the
California model or do you want the uh a
Florida model agreed to debate like it's
gonna happen yeah like they're actually
doing it when is it I don't know do we
know when this thing is we know when
this debate is
possibly November wow well that's it
more putting aside DeSantis for a second
the fact that new that the DNC or
somebody is letting Newsome do this
that's to me that's more a signal that
we're showing by it in the door that's
that's exactly my thought yeah or it's
not even that they're letting him it's
just like he's cueing here's the thing
if right he's laying in the groundwork
right because if something God forbid
happens to the president it come Kamala
Harris is not going to be a strong
candidate so it'd be very easy for him
to swoop in and take that from her wow
so is that what everyone like on the
Democrat side is saying like this is the
power moved by Newsome to figure out a
way to push Kamala out really because
Biden is just about the broken hip
they're actually doubling down on Biden
surprisingly
wow so they're really doing this good
for the sadness I mean yes this is you
know I've been saying it for at least a
year the fight America has to have is
the Florida versus Cali fight the fight
is not whether Biden or Trump should be
president at this point or whether we
can have another geriatric president or
all that stuff it's like do you want to
live in communist California or free
Florida that's absolutely awesome I'm
thrilled to hear that cool very cool uh
this is also a big one so a lot of times
conservatives
um
picture fit yeah yeah they want
something to happen nothing happens
um
they got President Biden to acknowledge
the granddaughter that Hunter had with
that stripper oh that is actually super
interesting because you know when I was
away so basically all I was doing I'm in
the rainforest and you know we were
eating right and working out and
drinking some tequila and whatever and I
was just every day I never watched TV or
anything even when I was doing cardio I
was just staring out into the forest so
I was really you're doing cardio in a
rainforest that is the most white people
think my life it's pretty sweet it's
pretty sweet you know little monkeys and
all this stuff but what I was really
trying to do was just clear the Clutter
out of my brain like the nonsense of
Twitter and the fighting and I was just
names that I don't need to know that
Earl and all the political I was just
literally like a file cabinet when I was
running I was just like get rid of that
thought get rid of that though it just
really remove stuff but one thing kept
popping up about about this about wait
what are we talking about uh the dawn
granddaughter oh the granddaughter sorry
the granddaughter Jesus
yeah I just went back there mentally did
you see that I was fully back in the
um but one and I was thinking about this
a bit like that is so profoundly screwed
up because it's not about politics it is
his grander so he finally said look he's
going to be involved in the kid's life
he just basically said I have this he
just acknowledged she existed it wasn't
any big deal it was just like oh you
know what I mean it was just like a
throwaway line but of course
conservative media understandably picked
up on it and they're like okay finally
as they should he is the grandfather Dr
Jill
oh
I hope that wasn't
yeah yeah yeah
um oh by the way we should tell people
it's a hundred degrees here yeah hottest
day in Milwaukee yeah of the year yeah
as the Republicans come to town yeah is
that some kind of biblical thing is it
because it's 70s every other day this
week but it's 100 right now I don't know
about the fact that I'm holding it
together in this Blazer is nothing I
took mine off I'm very proud man you're
okay thank you so much so um the other
thing I think that's interesting which I
don't think is discussed enough is a lot
of times when you talk about Hunter
Biden it almost seems like you're just
being salacious but yeah he shacked up
with his dead brother's wife
and the question I always had and it
sounds like a joke you never banged your
dead brother's wife I I don't have a
dead brother so no
um although my great my sister and I
have a very sick sense of humor and she
sent me photos of my nephew and she goes
he looks like you it's time for a DNA
test so yeah that's actually a kind of
joke that's weird it makes Mom very
uncomfortable yeah um do you think he
was shacking up with the wife before Bo
died or after because which is crazier
right which is crazy is it more sense
that they're doing uh what's that called
the Eiffel Tower or is it more sense
it's like hey I caught you at the
funeral I like the cut of your jib right
right which would be which was crazy
sort of just like ethically and morally
worse you're banging your brother's wife
on the DL while he's around or he diesel
that's what I'm saying oh that maybe it
wasn't even on the deal well by all
accounts Bo is a pretty decent guy I
feel like he would know that he yeah
right well I guess I don't know that who
knows who right who knows I don't know
um but wait I think we knew this did we
not know this yeah we knew that to me
that's the question about that Hunters
that's not discussed enough I'm like
this is really nuts yeah like the guy
well the guy's a crack addict there's a
lot going on with this guy well not
crack a crack Aficionado crack a fish no
I'm pretty sure when you're like in the
carpet looking for the parmesan cheese
we can call you an attic
um okay we're moving on we're only on
August 2nd Jesus okay we're so this is
the big one so also I do want to I
assume at some point we will dive back
into a little bit of what's going on
like with the numbers with all these
guys that are here tonight oh yeah okay
okay so Anheuser-Busch yes for the first
time cancer culture is working for
conservatives yeah they've been forced
to sell off several beer brands uh their
sales dropped 390 million in Quarter Two
unbelievable I've been allowed to use
the following word
by your staff okay I went to college
with the CEO uh uh Brendan Whitworth
okay I'm sure he does not remember me
okay and he was a complete insufferable
then and I saw him on Good Morning
America and nothing has changed so
was the word what's the word you got you
went for clearance on that I went for
clearance I don't want to get
demonetized
so are you surprised to hear this uh no
and I'm actually I think it's great like
it's an absolutely beautiful thing like
this is because it's not cancel culture
cancel culture is is top down really
like when they just randomly pick we're
going to cancel Roseanne Barr because
she made one off-color joke after
spending 40 years you know fighting all
the right fights and being a hero of
blue collar and minorities and blah blah
blah when a bunch of people are just
like we've had it with you forcing your
trans nonsense down our throat We're not
gonna drink this beer anymore Bud Light
and I guess it's now happening to some
other brands it's like that's a
beautiful thing that's that's what you
know like that's your choice as an
American you walk into the beer aisle
and you got 500 is easily at any major
supermarket and you can just be like I'm
just not drinking and it's not like Bud
Light snack I'm not a beer guy but like
it's not great well what do you drink I
I'm not a big drink I don't drink
because it makes me meaner yeah and you
are a very mean I am a meme you don't
want me being uh drunk I've actually
been hanging out with Roseanne a lot yes
yeah yeah uh one of the great privileges
of my life was taking a flight back from
her from Tim Poole's show and I'll just
I'll give you the like rosannies even
more Roseanne in real life yeah and she
is the least pretentious person I know
which makes no sense because she's in a
position to be she's far more of a
legend than either of us will ever be
yeah and we had like 15 minutes to get
on the flight
so we're at a restaurant she's trying to
eat quickly we don't have time so she
takes the sliders and and Fries put some
ketchup on a napkin brings the first
class I'm like you know you're bringing
the class to first class and Rosanna is
the only person who I feel comfortable
making fat jokes about to their face
because she's not fat anymore
so she goes you know after after I've
been stuffing my face all day like a pig
I'm gonna go home and take a long nap I
go as a pig
so it's she's an absolute treasure and
she has a new podcast yeah which is
superb I've been on it you know she uh I
think they invited me on the podcast I
was pretty close with her for a while in
La we sort of lost touch somewhat since
but uh one night we were at a party
a little of that and she's like you want
to get in my Tesla and I'd never been in
a Tesla before we get in her Tesla we're
in a residential neighborhood she's like
watch this and she presses the ludicrous
mode button which they don't have
anymore you remember what that was I
don't know they were literally like a
Spaceballs ludicrous mode where the car
would just explode but you're only
supposed to do that on the highway but
she did it like in the
middle of a residential neighborhood
it's a miracle I'm alive yeah she's an
absolutely absolutely oh she got out of
L.A she got out wow good for her the
other one good good
um oh this is a big one yes
it's funny because you've been off the
grid and me being me I feel like all of
these sound like I'm trolling you and
I'm not uh-oh so someone did some
research uh um in Obama's history you
know him's writing his autobiographies
which are very much mythological and
trying to create a narrative about who
he was and and they found letters that
had been suppressed where he was writing
to his ex-girlfriend at the time about
how he fantasizes daily about having sex
with men
wow so now you guys have something in
common
end the Stream
wait wow well this has been rumored this
has been oh that's funny this this has
been rumored for a long time right I
mean remember that there was that video
of like the gay prostitute right from
when Obama was running the first time so
this is what
2007. well if Barack Obama had a son he
would look like Andrew Gillum that's
funny uh so so wow and so this is
verified that this is legit I mean the
letters are very the letters are
verified he hasn't addressed it yeah
this is the point I made on Twitter and
I think it's actually it's funny but I
think it's true for a long time there
was this uh Mystique about political
figures yeah and Bill Clinton was never
asked about the pretty uh um
grounded rape accusations from Juanita
Broderick yeah and that dam broke I
think it was either I think it was in
2020 that that a reporter actually asked
him to his face and this was kind of
under the radar but to me it was a huge
moment that now instead of protecting oh
we can't ask him about this right right
no we're going to ask him at some point
I predict and this isn't a big
prediction someone is going to ask
former president Barack Obama did you
stop having gay fantasies after you got
married Michelle Obama and when that
happens it's going to be the funniest
thing on earth so basically you're
saying and I and I think I've roughly
been making this argument the protection
racket that the media used to have right
for the politicians he's coming to an
end yes there was a constant protection
racket where they could distract you and
keep you thinking about something else
you know who really broke it it was even
before 2020 with Juanita it was Trump in
2016 when he took all of Bill Clinton's
accusers to the debate remember that it
was Stuttering John when he asked
Jennifer Flowers if oh God sleep with
any other presidential candidates and
Bill Clinton used the condom so that was
in about 90 90
a little bit more about this so did
anyone care like was it or is it it's
the thing is so what maybe he's gay not
that there's anything wrong with that
like I don't really care but it's like
Jesus please like this is an
intervention I know what you've been
doing it was my super and when I lived
in New York City
um but like not that anyone really cares
but you know people people do say
Michelle is uh Joan Rivers you know yeah
Joan Rivers said that and then she died
but no I think it's not that people
really cared I it's good to be back it's
not to carry so much about the gay stuff
but it just speaks into the phoniness
yes because he always had this air and
people the the corporate press loved him
because he's every journalist what dream
they could read things into him and he's
yeah I'm just like you and you uh and
now it's kind of like this guy's kind of
a bit of a fraud did you see that
interview it was one of the last things
that we showed right before I left where
he's sitting down with some guy on
Comedy Central or something and they're
asking him because he wrote this like
top 10 songs of the year in top 10 books
that he read and all this and the guy
asked him so come on you listen to these
songs he's like tell me one lyric from
the song and Obama gets all like oh come
on don't make me do that you know what
really yeah and it's like wow so
was called and that's exactly
what you're talking about question if I
ask you like what's your favorite book
and I'm like name what's your scene oh I
like this moment no he literally that's
what he was doing it was like it was
like tell me what tell me what's that
book about what's that song about and
Obama's like are you gonna play me like
that you know what wow so the thing is
breaking beautiful beautiful yeah yeah
um okay we're only up to August 4th oh
my God okay
we're gonna skip to the oh this I didn't
have Obama as gay till at least August
28th so August 8th this is okay the
protection racket isn't entirely gone
it's a little different because they're
not asking Obama about it so it's it's
out there yeah this is really really
great yeah okay
I'm not again I'm not joking it sounds
like I'm joking yeah they found cocaine
at the White House we knew that okay I
knew that one yeah okay they did a
little investigation
they're like oh we did an investigation
it's fine they admitted it belonged to
one of the Biden family orbit members
but they're not following up in any way
and my point was
I don't care about the cocaine do blow
in the White House all you want yeah
this
This Rags this should be the most secure
building probably on Earth if you're
having powders floating around the White
House and you're not and this is public
knowledge this is a problem this is a
security risk the protection racket
really might be the biggest problem we
have in America more than anything else
because that sort of thing so you bring
Coke into the White House and I agree
basically like you want to do drugs in
your private time do whatever the hell
you want to do and everyone's done all
sorts of stuff fine but like if they
announced oh we found it we kind of know
who did it yes but also we're just we're
just shutting it down we're not going to
really go it's sort of like what they're
doing with him in his taxes he's
basically getting off scot-free unless
something unless you're about to tell me
something else oh really yes well Wesley
Snipes went to jail for three years for
federal tax evasion so you think Wesley
Snipes is feeling a little uh pissed
when he finds out that Hunter get all
the people going to jail for marijuana
when Hunters talking to the New Yorker
or the New York New York Magazine
whichever it was about smoking crack and
leaving his crack pipe in the Hertz or
when Kamala Harris was bragging joking
around that she smoked pot while she was
jailing all those people as Attorney
General
listening to set to Snoop who didn't
come out until after she was gone from
college so that was a lie as well did
you not remember that oh that's actually
hilarious
albums didn't come out so much later
it's like no he weren't yeah total fraud
um so that was kind of a big deal I like
that you're doing this in chronological
order not order of importance
necessarily it's interesting way of
hitting this keeping me on my toes okay
Dianne Feinstein
my second favorite senator I would
assume she's dead but I think we did
that we did the dead people okay she's
dead she's 90. yeah she tripped and fell
in San Francisco it was taken to the
hospital there is a lot of talk about
trying to pull her from the Senate she's
handed over I think power of attorney to
her daughter who's probably also
accepted yeah right
you're prying that Tennessee from her
cold dead hands I don't know if you
remember this and this also sounds like
a joke but it's not there was reporting
I believe it's the New York Post that
Chuck Schumer had sat down with her and
being like Diane you know you've got to
resign you're not all there you know
whatever and she agreed and then forgot
and he had to have this conversation
with her I believe three times you can
people can look this up so at the other
at the Other Extreme is like look
Republicans vote for Strom Thurman until
he was 99. yeah he's a reliable
Republican vote she's going to vote Dem
what would be the difference if you had
like in some random other Democrats it's
so funny because maybe that's the Off
the Grid thing that's the most
interesting like you bring up these
names so it's like this woman should be
you know home
not doing politics not in public schools
yeah exactly
but like people that have that have
offered nothing that have done nothing
right that sticker out it's just when
you step away from it for a little while
it's so obvious so she hasn't stepped
down she doesn't remember saying she was
going to step down correct and by the
way if she did say that publicly she
said to Schumer privately repeatedly but
if she did step down we end up with the
same thing that if Biden steps down we
get president Kamala Harris nobody wants
that if she steps down then Gavin has
the right to pick the replacement right
and some people are thinking wait a
minute stepped down so we could put
Kamala back in the Senate and that'll
free up the VP slot for someone who'll
add to the ticket Jesus which should be
a smart move for them man the Democrats
they they are you could say what they
want and the Republicans usually suck
sometimes they're a little bit better
you know as Peter Thiel says we have the
stupid party and the evil party the
Democrats of the evil party but then
we're just left with the stupid party
but like man you got to give him credit
for being so evil whatever that whatever
the the DeSantis Newsome thing that you
said that's the signal that's the signal
this thing is Biden is not going to be
running okay here's one
Joe manchin has left just like Kristen
Cinema left the Democratic party all
right he is caucusing as an independent
voting president so he's lost his
committee assignments all right so they
still have majorities 50 249 and we have
the clip from standard mansion
fat broads and horse-based lesbians
okay that was that was just a joke uh he
did not leave the Democratic party oh I
just wanted to have the clip of
Elizabeth Warren saying fat broads and
horse-faced lesbians
so that's why I don't have an ifb
apparently yeah he did not leave he did
not leave that he did oh but that was
legit but that's certainly worthy yeah
yeah okay I thought you're gonna pull a
fast one on me it would be much more
over the top than that I don't know what
else you've got in these papers well the
things are so crazy these all sound like
fast ones there was a woman arrested in
the teenage autistic girl was arrested
in the UK because she said when the cops
looks like her lesbian grandma and they
arrested her for this and the cop did
look like Megan Rapinoe it's not even a
question and she got arrested and then
they they freed her they apologized but
it's like who would arrested her for
what you can say that someone looks like
an old lesbian in the U.S I don't think
people in the US you know we always
complain about free speech and how yeah
cancer culture all that stuff I don't
think Americans are appreciating how
dark things are getting in terms of
speech in your broadly speaking and UK
specifically in Canada probably Canada
yeah
wait so they arrested an autistic woman
girl teenager it's not a teenage I'm
sorry it's a kid yeah and then but then
they did let her out after there was a
huge outcry yeah she's man yeah that
first amendment thing pretty good huh
yes happy to be here I am in America uh
in Milwaukee on this 100 degrees I'll be
honest yeah we do what we can with what
we have yeah so here's let's talk about
Hunter again okay so this was a very
interesting one uh that he had a plea
deal he was going to plea to something
you know and and have the judge started
sniffing around in this plea deal and
part of the hunter pleedio was that
basically he'd be absolved from any kind
of future prosecution from all sorts of
other things and the judge goes I'm not
signing off on this so the dude wait
that wasn't right at the end of the
month I sort of remember something right
at the end of July the deal fell through
yeah so now it's the case looks like
it's gonna actually be headed for trial
wow so that's a big one so protection
racket is 50 50. they appointed I
believe mayor Garland appointed an
independent Council to investigate uh
Hunter Biden uh Tim Scott uh already
started announcing him but who knows
where that's going to I'll go in any
direction right
again it's just like these are the most
corrupt people when you step away from
it then you start thinking about it the
cocaine at the White House the eighty
thousand dollars a month verisma deal
for the crackhead who had no experience
in Ukrainian energy it's like something
ain't right here but again so they take
him down which then maybe takes down
Biden and you get Kamala or you get gas
I'm gonna take down Biden no no if
somehow they could really figure out
that because Biden admitted it right the
the Ukrainian energy thing and firing
the prosecutor Biden admitted it all on
camera but there's no way my point is
that if there's just enough stink around
everything with Hunter and then people
are just done with Joe and the faculties
and everything it's like they could get
rid of him or push him aside and I think
it'd be very I don't think I think
people the tribes uh protect their own
so they're gonna very easily claim that
Hunters like you look they're targeting
his family leave the guy alone his kids
died already yeah and I think it'd be
very hard to push him off for this
reason maybe that's the the way then you
you really take out Hunter as the
sacrificial lamb as a way of garnering
sympathy
yeah and then you pardon him on your way
out God it's all okay babe it's all it's
right it's okay okay
yeah okay and this is I'm gonna have to
break it down because this is a long
complicated story that I wanted to add
but this is what's going on in Europe
okay so I'm gonna need a minute okay
Germany people in America like oh the
two parties suck we need a third party
you know blah blah many European
countries have like five six seven eight
parties Germany has six parties okay you
got the two main parties the social
Democrats the main Center left party the
CDU which is the main center right party
Angela merkel's party yep then you have
two right wing and two left-wing
subsidiary parties you have the left you
have the Linka which was the Communist
former Communists and the greens and
with the uh right side you had the free
Democrats which are basically kind of a
pro-business party and this recent
alternative for Deutschland which are
kind of far-right nationalists now oh
God are the Nazis back hold on so here's
the thing that term is used a lot yeah
naga's Nazi you know everyone's a Nazi
John as a Nazi there's a couple of wings
in this party and some of them are not
so nice and Dave you are Jewish you are
gay maybe they would have sterilized you
I don't know point being they have been
spiking in the polls after picking up
two actual minor wins they're now in
second place at 21 percent
there's talk now in Germany of
everyone's racking their brains what do
we do of trying to ban the party which
to me is completely insane first of all
who's bad political parties in Germany's
past number one but what are those 20
percent of Voters gonna do they're not
going to vanish and in fact there was an
election a regional election where there
was you know some dispute over the list
so they weren't on the ballot so another
party called citizens for rage took
their place and they got 10 which would
have been the 10 that afd got so my
concern is if you ban this party first
of all the they're gonna say with a
straight face we're the only party that
the establishment hates which is a great
vote for them second
what's their move then they go into the
main center right party they're in a
position to take it over because they
got 20 to vote who are radicalized so
what what would be like the most radical
position that they have or what what's
some of the rhetoric like it's really
like kick people out of the country it's
really bad it's like that kind of stuff
I feel guilty about World War II like
the guy Bjorn that's the thing unlike
the other so uh Victor Orban from
Hungary who gets announced uh Marine Le
Pen whose dad got in trouble for
Holocaust denial they both have been
distancing themself for afd because
they're like guys this is a little too
far even for us yeah so but the thing is
as they've become more radicalized
according to press reports their support
has increased it hasn't decreased well
almost everything that happens well
you've written a lot about this but
almost everything that happens on the
right when the weird stuff arises on the
right you don't have to look that far to
figure out how insane the left went to
cause it right so if you were a German
right now and you were like well what's
happened in Germany in the last 15 years
and I'm obviously not an expert in
Germany but with the amount of mass
migration that came when they literally
LED in over a million people I think
around 2 million people from all these
African countries in the Middle East
they gave them all these Services they
gave them homes they were something
spending something like four billion
dollars on dental work for these people
you take from the Native Germans and
then people get pissed energy bills
through the roof because Russia Ukraine
it's like why is this our fight yeah
rupture for a lot of people in Germany
it's like what are we doing here and
then and then of course the the moderate
the quote-unquote moderate parties they
don't say anything that's true or real
they don't want to deal with the issues
and you could probably put a lot of this
at the at the foot of Merkel right
because she's the one that led in all of
these people and then she she basically
remember what was it like two years ago
she kind of apologized for it she's like
well I guess that wasn't the best thing
we could have done and now you got the
the Nazi Nazi too wow all right this one
is the big one and this one uh we're
gonna have to talk about at some length
Okay this is the big one this is the big
one
Trump and 18 others
were indicted in Georgia oh oh so the
Georgia thing yeah including Rico
charges now which is a kind of a uh to
me RICO law is almost like Soviet law
because it could mean pretty much
anything it's used for gangsters
predominantly yeah and it's kind of like
if you two people were talking about
something that led to a crime you know
where it's legally considered a
conspiracy so some of the things in the
um charges were like well they sat down
they rented a room to meet that's that's
a that's a conspiracy the thing with the
Georgia law is this is not something
that you can be pardoned by as the
president this is a state indictment
number one
number two is if you wanted to get
pardoned the governor in Georgia is one
of the few Governors the governor who's
currently Governor Kemp obviously uh or
who or Stacy Israel Abrams who is
another black lives she was legitimately
elected let's say Kemp is the guy in
charge yeah they have some
um kind of committee which is currently
staffed I think by all Republicans uh
they would be the ones to make the
pardon but again they're not really a
like a partisan uh um Committee in that
sense or hearing whatever the term is
maybe Trump regrets going after Kemp so
hard but yes that is a very big deal and
as part of this let me read you about
the names of the 19 people okay uh some
of them are not our names I don't know
one so president Trump who is going to
be arrested I'm not joking he's going to
be arrested Thursday in Georgia
they are actually saying he's going to
be arrested I'm going down to Georgia to
surrender on Thursday he is going to be
arrested okay there's questions
what's next season yeah we got others
John Eastman his attorney okay here's
the other thing as Chris Christie knows
very well I'm not I'm not being glib
here these prosecutors know if they get
your lawyer to flip that's really really
bad yeah because your lawyer
attorney-client privilege is sacrosanct
American law usually yeah you tell your
lawyer what you did or like Hey how do
we work around this they've got the
goods so they flipped John Eastman he's
being charged wait sorry one question
what's the date on this where are we at
chronologically because now I'm sort of
amazed
the charges went down on August 14th
okay and they're going to Georgia this
week to turn themselves in and be
arrested Johnny Smith is one of them
here's a name that you're gonna be very
familiar to your mark Meadows you just
ran into his brother I ran into his
brother at the airport yesterday so Mark
I didn't talk to him I know nothing he
just said he likes the show
Forest
yeah in Atlanta she's the former Chief
of Staff here's another name Sydney
Powell
Rudy uh so my position is they've been
at it for Rudy for a long time because
he proved that you don't have to have
high crime rates in poverty in these
cities right these cities New York was
considered uncomfortable he showed that
when you have these out of control
cities you guys want this because by
Design and they've never forgiven him
for it he's being arrested you know I I
really love him so much you know I was
in New York during 9 11. you were a New
Yorker of course and also right like you
caused it with your disgusting
disgusting all right all right all right
not now Michael uh but I really you know
the last thing I did before I went off
the grid we did our goodbye show and
then at the last moment he was coming to
Miami so I did a show with him at locals
and then I was gone for the radio so the
last the last person in this world that
I talked to really before leaving was
Rudy and I just I even if he's
wrong on some of this stuff or whatever
I don't even know all the specifics he's
like a good man and you're right I think
they're going after him for that it
doesn't have to be this way he's one of
the people that shows that do you know
about the sexual harassment suit against
him no no I don't think so is that new
is that new can I say the t word on the
air the t word you already said it no
the other TW so part of this sexual
harassment claim against Rudy was that
he was sexually harassing one of her his
aides or she worked for him in some
staff in some capacity there's
apparently audio that was there's a
transcript in the in the uh filing and
he's talking about how I love your tits
those are my tits and so on and so forth
so there's another charge for Rudy as
well in that regard you're telling me a
guy likes tits well and that he owns her
tits oh he owned them I have not seen
set tits all right so who else is in
this thing
um so basically what the idea though is
that they want to get all these people
to flip on Trump like that well not only
that apparently Rudy's been flipping
they've been pointing the finger at
Sydney Powell because the Rudy approach
to 2020 it was very different from the
Sydney Powell approach so there's been a
lot of fingers this this happens all the
time with Ricoh charges you get everyone
together and everyone just starts
turning the finger yeah I'm sorry
pointing the finger to each other and
you can't blame them yeah it's like it's
like why am I going down with the ship
when this lunatic did the crime when I
didn't do anything I rented a room can I
tell you one thing about Sydney Powell
so I went to the White House holiday
party in 2020 so Trump was already on
his way out base but they were still in
the fight about the whole thing and you
know the day that I knew for sure that
the election fraud stuff at least from
her and that crew was nuts she was at
the party so it was the height still of
when they're like you know election
fraud and like all of the machines and
this like all the crazy stuff and she
was at the party for like five hours she
was still there at the end of the night
and I was like there's no way this stuff
could be real because you would not have
a moment you would not have one second
but she was dressed up dolled up hair
blah blah blah saw her at the Trump
Hotel after and I was just like no no
this makes no sense you can't be working
on the biggest conspiracy case of all
time and hanging out at the White House
Hanukkah party like what are you doing
lady so we've got one two three five
other lawyers I'm gonna go through their
names they're not familiar to me for
them Jeffrey Clark I was not familiar
with him Kenneth cheese bro uh Ray Smith
Robert Chesney and here's someone that
you are quite familiar with a certain
Jenna Ellis
wasn't she the one who went after you
publicly yeah she went after me publicly
when we announced we were having kids
but she actually personally apologized
to me yeah that's great to know yeah and
I accepted her apology and we're good on
that I can't speak to the her legal
expertise or that sort of thing uh David
Shaffer who is former chairman of the
GOP yeah a Georgia state senator Sean
still and three other names and of
course president Trump is the 19th uh
person and he's looking at uh I think
it's something like 700 years with all
these charges
I mean doesn't it seem to you that
they're just going to keep I don't know
if there's anything else still in the
docket because it seemed like Georgia
was the big one but okay so a DC one I
missed on August 1st now you're telling
me the George one which renew is coming
but haven't they already said that the
first the trial for the federal case
isn't it in it's next April or something
right they wanted so it's like right
before super Tuesday it's like they want
all of this to make everyone crazy
Alan dershowitz who you've had him yeah
who's obviously worked with Trump he's
hardly some kind of doctrina Republican
he's you know he's a lifelong Democrat
right so he's made the point publicly
that he believes that uh he will get
some convictions
uh that they will be overturned but
those overturns will happen after the
election so they're going to get what
they want ahead of time my yeah he could
still run while being convicted correct
yeah but there's a lot of talk in Maga
how this is a great thing for president
Trump and This is 40 chess I got to tell
you Karen is a big Swing Vote Karen
doesn't like voting for felons yeah and
I agree that this will have his base
double down and be like this guy's being
persecuted but we forget that the
average voter they're just sick of it
yeah they can't follow politics and if
they see a mug shot for a lot of people
that's enough to be like I'm not I'm I'm
not gonna either not gonna vote for him
or I'm just going to vote for the
opponent you know I'll tell you the
number one thing that people said to me
when they saw me yesterday at the in the
rainforest at the resort or when I've
seen people at the airport or at the
supermarket for the last month everyone
says the same thing to me a lot of
people are saying oh it's crazy it's
crazy but I would always calm them down
so that they didn't ruin it but the
other thing that they always say is like
I'm so sick of it I'm so sick of it and
I think that's partly what the machine
wants it wants you to be so sick of it
that you just freaking wave the white
flag and you're just like all right
we'll take the worst of the worst
because well also it's not them it's
that they might want to have Trump wave
the white flag and be like okay I'm not
going to run and this all goes away
that's not I'm sure there's talks do you
think it would be that simple actually
because that's that is a conspiracy
version of this thing they just want to
drop him down I'm going to say something
let's talk this out yeah because I know
you love to talk about the left and the
left yeah I don't think the left is a
monolith okay I think Nancy Pelosi is
not the same as AOC yep I think Nancy
Pelosi and Biden did a far better job of
shutting up Bernie Sanders and AOC than
the Republicans ever did because you
don't hear about the squad anymore
someone sat them down and be like you're
making us look bad and they vanish them
I think there is a big dispute behind
closed doors in the left so to speak do
we want Trump to go to jail
or do we want him as the nominee right
because because we think
we thought this before that he'd be an
easy defeat and downvotes would uh
devastate have you seen the uh there's a
compilation video that we played a few
days before I went off the grid where
it's all these people on The View and
MSNBC and CNN everybody saying basically
oh we want Trump to be the nominee Joy
they are we want Trump to be the nominee
Joy Reid we want people to be everyone
named Joy is a complete lunatic by the
way you ever notice that these people
named Joy they're always the most joyous
but he's on the vehicles how's your name
Joy you sit there like this you're like
oh that's good that's good and by the
way I also want to point out to all the
Nazis watching this Joy Behar is Italian
so stop we're not she's not our fault
yeah that's funny
um oh right because everyone thinks he's
Jewish but she's actually Italian stop
hitting her on us
um but the thing about the thing about
the Trump and it's like do they want it
to happen so that he's in jail or do you
want him to be the nominee thing is my
argument for DeSantis beyond all of the
uh the reasons that I think he is good
he actually can bring in new people
there's no people that Trump can bring
who's the new person that's like
suddenly like I'm voting for Trump now
so if you think the election what about
the staff like why would you here no and
then who can who's going to work for him
who's going to work here's the thing
this is something that Maga has to come
to terms with and I'm not saying you
shouldn't support Trump or should
because I'm an anarchist that's for
anyone why would I as someone who has
been nice being an anarchist you can do
this all day long and at the end be like
but you guys can all go after yourself
and I don't have to sweat it for some
reason look I have a long career I've
made a name for myself I've got a wife I
got a kids I got a family so on and so
forth husband and kids a family why
would I work for this guy yes when I'm
going to be charged as his lawyer with
Ricoh charges possibly disbarred my my
name is going to be ruined in perpetuity
and then if I quit her on fire he's
gonna go intro Central and call me an
idiot this is a something that Maga has
to Grapple with why would the people who
he would want to have his administration
put themselves through that and it's not
his fault to some extent but it's still
a concern you know the kill shot on that
one for me was the Kaylee mcenany attack
remember that yeah it was like what was
that probably beginning of July maybe
sometime in June when he just went off
on her for for not even doing much of
anything she just kind of said that she
likes a lot of what DeSantis is doing
she was the best of the best when I said
the the evil party in the stupid party
before the Republicans usually put out
these like stupid Fake Plastic she was
so freaking good height of covid in that
briefing room fighting with everybody a
Pro like Everyone likes her young mom
like good woman I you know I know her a
bit personally like
are they coming for us did you hear that
something that's happening out there
um and that was the one where I think I
think if you were on the fence of like
maybe I could work for Trump or
something like that it's like how do you
do it yeah that's just that's just
something they have to come to grips
with
um
Wayne Brady came out as pansexual
Wayne wait Wayne Brady What's My Line
not Tom Brady not Tom Brady whoa Wayne
Brady the black guy black guy he does a
lot of voices and stuff why is your
staff addressing me I I specifically
said I don't address do not address me
um Wayne Brady sexual so that's what he
likes to have sex with pans and pots red
pots yes yeah yeah what does that even
mean so I think that means you have sex
with because you can't say bisexual
anymore because that because that
implies too binary so pansexual meat
listen I always thought he was gay or
something like he was one of these like
he's like one of these guys you know
let's let's keep the homophobia to a
minute you you freaking Nazi sorry sorry
this is two hours from America's
favorite Nazi Dave Rubin does anyone
care about these things anymore like is
there was there anyone in America so
Wayne Brady all washed up he's not
washed hold on this is what I would
guess yeah I would guess that someone
has receipts of him with a transgender
woman so he came out to be so clever and
no no if he wants to more power to you
Mr Brady I don't care you ever see the
the meme it's a two-picture meme of a
girl you only see her sitting at a table
at a restaurant and she says I'm
pansexual and then the next panel is
just her with a giant pen in her mouth
laughs
um okay we're up to August 14th yeah
I could see cast iron maybe but just a
regular pan like a non-stick pan and
Janet Yellen yeah who what the one thing
I like about Janet Yellen I'm from
Brooklyn uh all my life people don't
have that accent anymore like it's no I
know it's I know I know I'm like we must
preserve this as much as we can it's
even as much as I hate Bernie it's a
little uh I can deal with it
she admitted that when she was in China
China
she had psychedelic mushrooms
wait like now or
what yeah
Janet Yellen yep
she was stripping face buddy
yeah
yeah you know in the rainforest I did a
little rattlesnake poison I micro dosed
on Rattlesnake but we'll that's a story
for another toad Venom you did
rattlesnake it was rattlesnake venom in
the in the uh specialized tequila okay
different story uh what yeah
intentionally I don't remember if it was
intentional it wasn't a big deal it was
just like okay I took it I don't think
it was really sweet well now well like
while she's I think it was some kind of
cultural thing there to kind of get you
like buzzed it wasn't like she was like
tripping face and naked on the beach or
whatever right right I mean I got no
problem with someone doing mushrooms but
I guess that we have a problem with our
big nation and tripping is transitory so
yeah absolutely like inflation yeah
um this is a big one this is not funny
it's very sad there's a huge uh wildfire
in Maui uh over 100 people are dead
um it's been going on for quite a bit
apparently there was some drama about
releasing water in terms of equity uh
and that made the situation worse Biden
finally came to visit after a long time
people were cursing him out uh the
scenes are horrific
um wow 100 people dead in a fire yeah
and it's it's been going on it's it's
been really really bad
um and it's just like there's nothing
you can really say but it's like your
heart obviously goes out to the Hawaiian
people and it's just it's awful yeah
well I am sorry to hear it yeah yeah
that's not that's not funny at all okay
so August we're up to August we're
almost caught up wow we're almost there
man okay we're only an hour in okay I
have a lot to talk about okay so part of
the debates tonight
you had to sign a loyalty oath Trump
refused to do so so tonight he is going
to be releasing I think a pre-taped
interview with Tucker Carlson as counter
programming and I want to hear your
thoughts about why this could be a good
move for him and why it could be a bad
move I could see either way right right
so first off as far as the pledge I mean
he may just be using it's a ploy one way
or another right like it's a ploy I
think it is Applause
we remember in 2016 during the debates
the 2016 season that was like the first
question I think that was about him yeah
who asked yeah is there anyone here who
will not agree to support the nominee
and Trump was the only one who raised
his hand he told I mean the others were
lying because they didn't support him
and he goes I don't I can't I don't know
what some of these guys stand for I
can't say I'm going to admit to support
them yeah
um Trump is now very fairly saying it's
like look if Chris Christie's the
nominee this guy can't get my name out
of his mouth why would I be supporting
him I can't commit to that so well of
course the art the argument against that
though is that in essence then you're
you're basically voting for a Democrat
you're supporting a Democrat so right if
you don't push the base to even if it
was Chris Christie who's a big nothing
and obviously we'll be out after tonight
but like you then in essence are saying
okay let's have a Democrat president
that that's the argument against the
base version of that when I say it's a
ploy what I mean really though is that
it's a ploy in that if he did not want
to debate because he does not want to be
up there tonight because he's number one
and he wants and what he really wants
and I don't know what the numbers are
maybe you can tell me what the latest
numbers are like if what he really wants
is everyone to attack DeSantis which is
what's going to happen tonight and he'll
unleash Vivek on DeSantis
um if that's what he really wants then
that seems like a good play like you
just sit out of it and I'm I'm bigger
than everybody like there's you know
it's imagination then the guy's a TV
star you know the only uh reality show I
ever watch in my entire life literally
literally was Celebrity Apprentice so
this is the type of thing that he does
right funny story The I'm not this is
also not a the first part of this is not
a joke the women in Real Housewife lives
that very successful very powerful
franchise they're Bethany Franklin who's
the yeah and a bunch of them they're
thinking of unionizing and I suggested
that that's the funniest thing I've ever
heard from the Special Olympics but yes
this is their actual thing of unionizing
that's hilarious as if they're broke and
then Andy Cohen will have to come out as
the anti-union guy you know the good
hero you know but let's talk about the
debate Dynamics yeah because I think
this is something that bears a lot of uh
breaking down
DeSantis has has been slipping heavily
in the polls okay
um I you know a lot of people on the
campaign and a lot of his surrogates
um in my experience and opinion I've I
know people in the campaign I've invited
them on my show I had you on my show you
made the case for DeSantis I asked you
questions critical questions you answer
them adroitly they were not
non-offensive they're kind of not doing
a lot of like podcasts and things like
this which I think is a huge mistake is
he still so when I left he had just done
Russell Brand which was great he had
just done Megan Kelly uh he had done a
few more he had a lot of like he's uh
what's her name um Christina Christina
who's superb she's not she hasn't been
out there yeah to me it was such a great
spokesperson she's not out there as much
as I would like her to be interesting uh
and at the same time you have people
like like Bill Mitchell who are trying
to tweet can we have the clip from Bill
oh no
I look like an aging lesbian
okay and he just recently debated Laura
Loomer on Sim pool and Laura just
completely this because she's she's a
she's a she's a human chainsaw right
these people though like Bill Mitchell
or Illumina
here's my point if you're at the
DeSantis campaign why is Bill Mitchell
the guy who you're sending out well did
they send him out I doubt he I doubt he
isn't but you mean why is it because if
you're not sending out your people then
you're going to get it on him and Tim
cool said explicitly I have Tim has a
very fair show he's got people on the
left people on the right you've done it
I'm sure yeah he's like anyone can
understand his campaign come out here
he's on for Trump but you'll have a fair
hearing it's free TV well I think I
think I have a thing in DC around middle
of September and I just spoke to Tim
yesterday about something else and I'm
going to uh I'll try to get out there
and I'll I'll gladly do it but yes it
should not be me and I'm not a surrogate
for the campaign or paid or anything I
happen to think he's the best candid but
am I so is that fair to say that so the
polls have changed a little bit is that
what you're doing so here's what's been
happening is that Trump and then I'll
try to hit that point a little bit more
that you're asking so basically DeSantis
has been kind of nose diving a lot the
vague as the kind of Trump without the
drama candidate has been surging a bit
um and in my that's sort of consistent
to where sure
it's been continuing the trajectory but
what I think is going to be interesting
tonight I'm going to strongly disagree
with you when you say that Chris
Christie is going to be over tonight
Chris Christie I I love using all the
puns with him really punched above his
weight in 2016. because I think you
might remember he was the one who broke
Marco Rubio because marquery was saying
Barack Obama don't act like Barack Obama
does nobody's doing he knows exactly
what he's doing Chris Christie goes
Marco you're just coming here with these
panned lines and just repeating them
yeah and Ruby and just repeating Rubio
just kind of broke down yeah he's like
look at him he's like a robot yeah so he
has been very articulate in the
anti-trump case in that he's been
speaking here's the thing I I bring this
up all the time I wish I could remember
the pundit who made this point in
2015-16 because it was a brilliant point
which was Christie's whole shtick is on
the obnoxious loudmouth New Yorker who
Ruffles Democrats feathers and says
things that no one else will say and you
know gets elected as a result Trump
comes in and Christy's like what's my
Lane yeah yeah but he was really good at
at that when he's Jersey Mafia instead
of New York mafia yeah yeah put away
Jerry kushner's Dad yeah you know people
don't remember this look it up yeah he
put him away because Jared kushner's dad
tricked his own brother secretly
videotaped him with a prostitute this
look this up this sounds it's just
complete crazy stuff so there's a lot of
animosity between the the Kushner family
and the Chris and Chris Christie all
although one of the kushner's donated to
Christie's campaign uh Murray or Murray
Murray I forgot his name just recently A
minor Kushner figure point being Chris
Christie has been making the point
Trump's a loser we lost the midterms uh
we lost 2020. this guy's a guaranteed
loser felony and as a former prosecutor
he knows Rico is no joke this is
something that's very ambiguous law so I
think he's the one people shouldn't
sleep on tonight that's interesting I
mean so my sleeper although I don't like
it I'm not saying I like him yeah no I
got it my sleeper all along has been
Nikki because I think the more that the
craziness get ramped up where I know you
definitely disagree with her on foreign
policy for sure
um and I have some disagreements which
I've discussed with her on on the show
not too long ago but I think she will
consistently be seen as sort of like the
same middle person in all the fighting
and she will kind of people won't want
to attack her as much so I think they're
I think she's the Dark Horse the thing
with Chris hold on hold on and we also
know that unlike her former boss she's
not going to vanish in the wilderness to
scissor her mistress for a few days God
knows how where that was funny thank you
I got it scissors that was good
um but the thing with Christy is you
might be right that he'll he might have
a nice moment up here tonight like he
could just maybe hit DeSantis out of
nowhere or something like that but it
depends what the I don't know what all
the uh all the qualifications are for
the subsequent debates right you know
right now we know it was the 40 000
individual donors and all that he just
doesn't have any real support so he
might have some lights yeah he's like in
second or third in New Hampshire uh the
the criterions for the debate listen if
what's his name how far did he make a
program if both of them doesn't make it
tonight I don't know my point is if you
have ASA Hutchinson making these debates
and I really think it would look doesn't
that feel made up like they let pogram
and ASA Hudson hold on but you remember
in 2016 they had to have the kids table
remember they weren't there literally 17
candidates oh right so it is it who's
the Republican party to have the
Criterion be fairly low yeah because
they don't want to look like the DNC
where it's just like look we're just
gonna gin it for Hillary so they eight
people I don't think is a crazy number
to have on that stage no no eight eight
is a perfectly good number for a first
debate I have to say though the Larry
Elder thing just personally is
disappointing to me because his message
is good and and maybe Tim Scott will
share some of that message but that
that's that's kind of disappointing but
Christy I just don't know where the
people that are going to come out and
and support him really are but I think
you're right for television purposes or
for the hit yeah punch the body slam so
to speak yeah he might do something he's
going to be a real heavyweight debater
yeah um I also think that the knives are
out for the vague interesting he's been
really over performing yeah he's been
doing he just had a big beef this
morning uh he was on Caitlyn Collins
show on CNN he went back and forth with
her claiming he was taken out of context
uh the Atlantic uh in an Atlantic
interview uh the Atlantic released the
audio of the interview this morning this
is breaking today day but he's been
making a lot of waves um he's been taken
out of context for what he had this
point about 9 11 about how like look we
don't know the whole story so on and so
forth here's the whole thing let's talk
about this you know how the corporate
press works which is if you say we don't
know the whole story about 9 11 it can
range anything from missiles hit the
Twin Towers to the following which is
undisputably true their rapacious
redacted from the 911 report maybe just
finally but the point is the government
has kept certain things from the public
maybe they had to that's the but the
point is it's literally impossible to
say we know everything right of course
maybe we should know everything because
then the terrorists are going to know we
know it's a meta argument about whether
States should have any secrets right so
this you know this kind of blew up I'm
not I don't have the exact details a
hundred percent but they've been going
back and forth but he's been doing the
Trump thing as something which I adore
he understands that the enemy isn't
necessarily from his perspective the
Democratic party it is the media who is
doing their dirty work for them so
they've been going back and forth this
morning well interesting so we're you
know tonight we're doing the post debate
show from right here and and I think uh
we're we're working on it but it looks
like we'll probably have the governor
and Nikki and Vivek and a few of the
others that'll come up here Vivek right
after uh you know I got into a beef with
him okay uh in July because he was
relentless oh you did right he was
relentlessly going after DeSantis
refusing to go after Trump and he kept
saying that DeSantis signed a hate
speech law in Florida and it was not a
hate speech it was a property rights law
and I went through the all the all the
little bullet points of it it was about
property rights there's nothing that you
can't say in Ohio where he's that you
can say in Ohio where he's from did you
that you were a filthy Leslie oh you
just to prove that I would not get in
trouble right and I stand by that
statement but the point is it's not a
hate speech law because there's nothing
that you can say in Ohio that you can't
say in Florida but I will ask him about
that tonight so you kept saying it was a
Hate by the way we agreed to shelve it
and and um Laura Ingram on Fox one or
two nights before I went off the grid
she played a clip of me and tried to get
him to go after me and he basically took
the high road and I immediately texted
him after I said look you took the high
road I'll take the high road I tweeted
it out we'll we'll work it out I don't
think you're evil I disagreed with you
on that thing and be happy to talk about
it with him here tonight there's been a
lot of opposition but look if he starts
going up you're going to get the hits
It's how it works there's been a lot of
Oppo opposition research dropping
against him there was a clip and this I
please double check me on this I'm not
100 where he has come out and supposedly
please double check me uh in favor of
the inheritance tax saying something the
effect that you know just horrible idea
just because you're wealthy your kids
shouldn't have that big Advantage uh
again for the report right that seems
crazy uh he's obviously extremely
wealthy more power to him uh minus you
know he's earned that money but for me
and many other people even Whoopi
Goldberg uh of all people had this is
years ago she's like it's a complete
non-starter yeah I pay my income taxes
this is my money like what are you
talking about it's such a criminal thing
and it should you know it should be what
do they call it so sometimes they call
it the estate tax the wealth tax or the
the death tax but it really is CR it
really is Criminal if you think about it
does not matter whether you think poor
people should have more money or
anything else the idea that after you've
done everything right your whole life
you pay into the system you do all of
that you should have every right to
leave your money that has been taxed all
along the way to whoever you want that
the government will just be like yes
we're taking 40 percent of that by the
way to throw it to give Ukraine more
bombs or to build more houses
are worse than that because this comes
out of the 1890s early 1900s
progressivism where their whole idea is
no one should have advantages early on
in life yeah their way it would be 100
because that everyone should be starting
off equally which is completely
ridiculous except for them was somebody
smarter or taller or whatever gonna have
some advantages something better
nutrition right so you're gonna have to
hit a lot of smart kids with a hammer
yeah exactly exactly so I think it's
well interesting that's interesting
about him please ask him about that yeah
because I want to make sure I got that
right I don't want to be misquoting him
I will I will oh wait sorry but just
last point on that so you're saying his
reaction to it has been to just
basically fight the media sort of do the
Trump version he said it on on CNN last
night he's like look you guys miscope
people take things out of context all
the time
um this is how you guys operate I I you
know this started I think one of the
earliest moments of this was in 2012
when I forget the guy's name with a huge
Jaw from CNN I had new Cambridge on John
King John King he had King which on in
the presidential debate and the first
question he asked nuking which former
speaker of the house is is it true that
when you had your first divorce you had
asked your wife at one point for an open
marriage and Newt Gingrich goes this
we're deciding the next president and
first of all it's false but for you to
ask this is very close to Despicable I
think those are news words Gingrich was
pretty good yeah I think it was 2016 it
was Ted Cruz who was just like you're
asking me us to fight against each other
online gambling these aren't the
questions America what is wrong with you
people and after that the Republicans
said they would never do another debate
with what I think with CNBC uh or MSNBC
who was hosting I think with CNBC point
being it's been a very effective and in
my personal opinion correct strategy for
the Republicans to be like these guys
have an agenda yeah and it's important
to call them out on it instead of just
pretending these are objective questions
look although I've been obviously
somewhat frustrated by Trump for the
last couple months like I fully give him
credit for that he red pilled more
people than any of us ever could me and
you for the rest of our lives screaming
about it and everyone we know he red
pilled people about phase one exception
and what only Rosie O'Donnell
what you remember that the first debate
oh that she yeah what was it that uh
what would you call women pigs
uh you know Port we've Rosie and I used
to be close too and I had to unfollower
on Twitter because she he broke her and
I was just like I unfollowed her out of
out of pity in a way because it was like
I just don't want to hate you so I'm
just gonna hold up hold on
if you're a high school bully
became president you know I get it you'd
lose your mind too I I said she gets a
pass I said to Bill Maher on his podcast
your Trump derangement syndrome I give
you a pass because he goes after you
personally the Trump every day was like
Dave rubin's
you know whatever wait do you have
anything else to understand this
otherwise I just want to address that
point a little harder um the point about
the surrogates and all that you know one
of those one point about this okay so we
I I can I can say but it's a minor one
but basically he had a big campaign
shake up so it was a public
acknowledgment that things aren't where
they should be yeah and I have to say
from my personal perspective I have been
at this a long time you and I both have
I have never in my lifetime seen as much
of a sea change in terms of perception
of a candidate yeah from DeSantis who in
October of 2022 I think every Trump
voter would say this is the greatest
government we've ever Governor we've
ever seen yeah and then the day after he
announces well he's another Jeb Bush
I've never seen such a switch in my life
you know Charlie Kirk and I did a did
you see any of it uh Charlie Kirk and I
did an interview on his show right
before I went off the grid where we got
into it about that and he kept saying
you know you just don't turn on the base
you don't turn on the bass and I
basically said to Charlie you know name
one thing DeSantis has done wrong who
was the best on code but I got him to
say all the nice things about uh about
DeSantis I said do you think he has
anything to do with
um what's his name Paul Ryan or Karl
Rove and Charlie Soros it's all it's
they all know it's all made up and
actually one of the things I was
thinking Off the Grid is I was purging a
lot of the thoughts this thing that
you're mentioning that the guy DeSantis
went from wow this is the guy who won
the state by 20 points he's the standard
bearer of everything we've all wanted
out of a republican good young family
man in the military lawyer crushing his
opponents turning Florida which was
basically blue and then purple now to
the most red state in the nation this is
the best guy we got and one thought that
I did have constantly over the break uh
sort of like philosophically is that
Trump did do something with a very dark
power here if you can take the guy that
everyone thought was the best was the
successor you know all that stuff and
that you can make the base hate him
purely on lies that was the point it's
purely online I'm not saying I'm not
telling you he's perfect I disagree with
him on the abortion thing for example
But like everyone knows even the people
that are being critical of him know that
this is this is the best candidate right
now like in a holistic sense I really
believe that
but Trump turned a huge amount of people
against him that's a very dark power to
have if you do it all based on lies
saying he's working with Soros saying
he's friends with Paul Ryan who Trump
had far more to do with Paul Ryan all
those things don't you view that as like
a do you see what I'm saying like
there's a dark energy to that if you can
just manufacture a hatred of somebody
that's dangerous I'm gonna disagree a
little bit Yeah
and kind of You can disagree a lot yeah
every Republican is going to have to
face this because literally whoever the
nominee is going to be portrayed as
Hitler literally Hitler right sure but
the fact that it came from Trump not
from the media my point is as well as
the Republican or even a prominent
Republican you are going to have to know
that there there's not going to be
anything that depth that they won't sink
a good example of this which happened
way before you went on your uh
sabbatical is uh his wife had cancer I
think she's better now thank God he took
a day off no wonder where he was because
she had cancer treatments and there are
articles being like Oh your wife has
cancer when you step down and it's just
like completely Shameless completely
despicable uh to just a really nasty low
blow the point is you knew you're going
after Trump right if you're gonna
announce you knew who you're facing
Trump is not a mysterious Secret at this
point you know exactly you're going up
against so you as the campaign you know
he's going to hit you high he's going to
hit you low he's going to go after
everything nothing's gonna be held
sacred it is your responsibility as the
campaign to be ready for that yeah and
to have a counter punch and to be able
to not let your opponents Define you uh
and he's been doing his campaign has
done a very bad job I I think that's a
fully Fair critique and look I think
I've probably been again I'm not a
surrogate and that I'm not on the
campaign or paid or anything like that
but I'm just telling people what I
believe to be true I think I've probably
done a better job than virtually
everyone associated with them I'm just
saying again what I think is right and
true but the idea that yes maybe you
stepped into this not realizing that he
was going to go to the Gates of Hell to
destroy for you but I just think I guess
I get that naive the scientist is not
that naive the Santa is a very bright
man no no or they didn't strategize it
right right okay so that they were like
okay well we're going against Trump we
know that if he's going after Kaylee and
you're gonna challenge her nomination
he's going after you right but what do
you think about what I said about just I
just mean this philosophically that that
Trump is using something that we all
hate the media for we all hate the media
for its Endless Lies and that it can
turn good people into bad people and and
it can literally just 180 the truth all
the time and you I quote you every day
on my show the corporate press is the
animelia people that's a dark power and
Trump is also using just the other
version of that dark power the other
side of the coin on that and I and I
guess that I don't know maybe I'm like
well I don't know maybe I've been off
the grid so politics is like here's the
thing we remember when he was just like
Ted Cruz your dad
questions about the JFK assassination
Ted Cruz like what what the hell are you
talking no he basically said Ted Cruz's
dad kill JFK right all of the craziest
the point being I think uh this is a big
unforced error on the distance you might
be right you might have brought up the
afd in terms of Germany uh and I do not
want to at all compare uh Maga to the
afd in terms of their views what I'm
saying is if you have that 40
ride or die yeah of the Republican party
for Trump we are going to vote for him
if he's in the electric chair I don't
care right what happens to that 40
percent if he's forced off the ticket
yeah they've got to go somewhere and I
don't think there's an obvious Plan B
for them but the the iron this the irony
or the sadness I suppose is that these
people all love DeSantis a few months
ago as you pointed out and they would
all love him as president and I think he
would be a much better president for
what Maga actually is and accomplished
and hire the right people and and all of
those things and again right now I'm
being a better quote-unquote surrogate
yes then maybe his guys are but it's
like this this is the guy that you were
all waiting for and and that Trump said
no this has to be me again or let's
blow up the whole thing is uh I
don't know maybe I'll feel a little bit
differently after I'm on the grid for a
couple weeks I was talking to prominent
conservative on the phone the other day
and he made the point and this actually
kind of rang true the fear and I don't
think this is crazy because we don't
know ahead of time because he's not
president yet is that he would do a much
uh uh he would be much more playing ball
with the establishment than it would
look like as his role as a governor
where you're basically the executive and
that's not an impossible hypothesis it's
no it's not an impossible hypothesis but
I think you can just look at someone's
track record and what is this guy said
that he didn't accomplish what what is
he like massively lied about he turned I
mean you look at in any other election
if Trump didn't exist right now and we
don't have to do hours on Trump right
now but like if Trump if Trump wasn't
running right now all these people would
be supporting DeSantis and in any put
remove this presidential election if
there was just put us on a slightly
different planet and a guy wins by 20
points and like completely flips the
political system and then becomes the
place where everyone's moving to that
the economy is flourishing and is safe
everybody would be like uh maybe that's
the guy you know what they know they
would be saying he's a hate Monger no no
those people yes the machine people yes
exactly I'm talking about
we the people who are somewhat free
thinking and are willing to agree to
disagree and that are Maga in that
you've got Rudy Giuliani who's
pro-choice along with the evangelicals
who are pro-life that thing most of them
would be looking at DeSantis like you
know so we'll we'll see that's
interesting and we'll see what happens
tonight one of his big donors said he's
not giving him any more money I think
surprisingly from my understanding and
uh please double check me at home I
think Tim Scott other than Vivek is like
in terms of fundraising has done a
superb job which is maybe flipped he
turned money from his Senate campaigns
because he had like a nominal position
um but the fun the Mike Pence apparently
was on the bubble in terms of
fundraising he's not making a lot of
money I'm shocked he got 40 000 people
to support him because I have not met
one Mike
donate a dollar no it's a dollar it
literally is a dollar so you just right
right you're the former VP yeah you can
figure it out um so he I I I I I I mean
I mean let's just go through this let's
suppose Trump is kicking wait do you
know when the first primary is isn't it
like January something yeah it's January
so it's funny we're in August right now
and the last thing that I was hearing
the week before I left all the trouble
just add this must step down yeah it's
like guys guys we're seven months off
the thing now you know roughly so come
on uh another one which is kind of a a
big deal and this is something that is
interesting
um there
uh oh they're talking covet again uh in
Hollywood they're having Mass mandates
again I've started seeing matches go for
it Cali well no there I mean there's
talk about this to be very easy for them
in terms of the election to kind of have
the same system that was so effective
for them in 2020. so the The Feelers
have been coming out in the press that
there's going to be another wave and we
might have to do all the sort of things
again I live in the Free State of
Florida and I'm never putting on a mask
again and I did not get injected and I
will never be injected and it's complete
well yes in terms of the turnout
yeah could you look imagine if it was
DeSantis who has now signed all these
laws that you'll never enforce them
you're not hearing me no no I got you
what I'm saying is you might be right
they could just manufacture it a month
before the election get everybody afraid
and then it makes Florida look insane
that's what I'm saying what I'm saying
is it might be very easy to do mail-in
ballots and all that no I got it I got
it but meaning you'd scare the hell out
of everybody and then be like oh and the
nominee is the most anti-coveted safe
person that you could possibly possibly
imagine that would work more against
DeSantis than it would even against
Trump because Trump obviously did work
speed and everything else um yeah that's
horseshit and people are falling for it
like they're really bringing it back
later in the last week oh my God here's
the other point here's a prediction I
made yes uh and people called me crazy
but I don't think it's that crazy if
Trump is forced off the ballot for some
reason yeah and there's a lot of talk
that we don't even need his agreement
that if you like a former Confederate if
you had uh uh like I forget what the
term was being an insurrectionist
therefore Congress can just declare that
you can't be a candidate for a federal
office I would bet Junior runs as his
surrogate
listen I like Junior a lot why why did
Trump do that be like all right you
can't have me have my son Junior and I
have been friends for years I I would
have no problem with Junior running it
doesn't change how I feel about the
governor uh DeSantis obviously Junior's
a good dude we've been friends for over
a decade well before his dad was in
politics
um we I I think I mentioned it on my
show a few weeks before I went off the
grid we haven't spoken since sort of the
it got hot related to the two of them
and I texted him and I said hey Don just
want you to know like I put friendship
over politics he immediately responded
with the nicest possible thing he said
Dave we may want to kill each other
throughout this but we are good to go
and we'll break bread and like that
that's what it's all about and look that
takes a lot of the baggage away right it
does take a lot of the baggage and it
keeps some of the energy so so did the
Mitch McConnell thing happen before you
left when he had a stroke just standing
there so was it a stroke or we don't
really know there hasn't been a lot of
follow-up there is some quiet buzz in
the Republican Senate and within Mitch
McConnell's office as well that maybe
it's time for him to step down
these people can you believe that these
people have anything to do with us I
gotta tell you John I donated money to
Better Man uh he's I'm serious he's my
favorite I'd much rather have him in
office than Oz yeah uh he's my favorite
Senator by far
um My Hope Is that he one day snaps and
goes on Of Mice and Men Rampage on the
senate floor
um or oh God you think he's gonna like
take AOC and Crush her yeah yeah I mean
is that not implies
um and just really just go ham on uh you
know Dianne Feinstein in her wheelchair
oh good God yeah it would be like a
beginning of a Marvel movie or something
yeah he just recently had a photo of
himself hoping holding up a veggie tray
and he wasn't pointing at his head he
was pointing at like and broccoli so the
other thing is that I I think those are
the kind of the big
um big stories I think we hit them all I
wanted to make sure that so the main
thing is that PeeWee Herman did die I
don't think that's
did you hear about the stuff about
um uh what's that um uh Human
Trafficking movie that Santa Freedom
yeah was that breaking before you left
oh yeah it was crushing it and did it
beat Indiana Jones yeah Bloomberg this
was very disturbing to me Bloomberg had
a reporter denounced it a Critic and the
guy's name was Noah berlotsky and he
worked for it he worked for location
frustration what it's called which is
pro pedophile rights or destigmatizing
whatever and I tweeted at every single
person on the Bloomberg opinion staff
I'm like was this your decision do you
support it they of course all ignored me
so at a certain point in my view uh if
the corporate press were one percent as
concerned about child abuse as they were
about climate change things would be a
lot better there was an article in
Canada's Globe and Mail in editorial by
a priest and the headline was the far
rights concern over pedophilia is
dangerous and I'm like you know
if this is where people are freaking out
about I think this is something that's
right and I gotta tell you I also don't
like it and I'm sure you'll agree when
conservatives are trying to make it a
partisan issue not in terms of who's
fighting it but in terms of who's
perpetrating it because the people who
are committing these acts across all
lines you don't protect their voter
registration they go to where the kids
are this is something that uh I talk a
lot about because a friend of mine came
out and when I talked about on Rogan
with his permission several other my
friends came out I remember I remember
yeah this is something I'm an uncle now
of two nephews this is something I think
needs to be discussed more
um it's just very disturbing to me how
common apparently it is and we don't
have the language to discuss it if
someone's dad was a drunk if your mom
you know was violent we could talk about
it oh that sucks but people feel the
need to hold this as a secret and then
they're suffering all their lives so I'm
glad this is being discussed more and
I'm disturbed by these attempts to
downplay concerns about it it's really
bizarre also because every one of us was
a child and most of us hopefully we'll
have children or you have nieces and
nephews or whatever it is and and do you
remember when when Elon took over
Twitter how suddenly out of no oh I
think maybe you you might have tweeted
about this before anyone yes how
suddenly child abuse the problem
suddenly child abuse was a problem on
Twitter so these people who had never
written about uh child porn on Twitter
that's what it was about they had never
written about it once suddenly all of
these headlines out of nowhere Elon has
a huge problem with child porn on
Twitter I was like well wait a minute
you guys did not care about it the
entire time then a guy comes in who says
there's a problem and we're trying to
resolve it now you're trying to take him
out right like it really it's so Twisted
yeah I I remember that because I all
those reporters who were like writing
headlines I just searched oh that's what
it was I searched for their Twitter feed
I'm like have you written about this
before and now you start carrying that
Elon took over it's like do you really
care about the issue or do you care that
this is a cultural for you to hit Elon
over the head with yeah and so you to
leverage this as a gotcha moment to me
is so gross uh it's it's something that
is so prevalent and again it's not a
political thing I know that some
conservatives like think everyone's
either Republican or Democrat they're
like I hear this a lot on social media
like oh everyone riding in in 20 uh uh
uh 20 where Democrats it's like these
people aren't civic-minded citizens
they're not registered to vote like yeah
you consider them out group but come on
they don't really have opinions on the
estate taxes climate change they just
want they're just criminal so uh I think
it just does a big disservice to kind of
try to make it uh Dennis Haster former
speaker of the house obviously went to
jail yeah so see with this so it's just
very sick stuff uh slightly unrelated
because we shouldn't end on uh we got
some time oh okay
um did anything happen in terms of like
censorship Free Speech Twitter like
anything in that department was anyone
big booted off YouTube any any of that
kind of stuff that is yes that's a
that's a great cue this actually brings
up locals it's kind of interesting so
Kurt Metzger who I mentioned earlier had
this great joke I saw him in uh Austin
where he made the comment he goes Paul
and again conservatives don't know how
to take a win like if things get better
they don't realize that they used to
complaining like here's a very obvious
example I'm sure everyone listening to
this remembers we need more Muslim
immigration we need more Muslims
immigration refugees welcome here yeah
because your con was sold in the
Constitution Hillary Clinton's
Democratic Convention that backfired
like people like we don't want this and
then just stop talking about it
yeah but conservatives don't acknowledge
their victory
so we all remember Paula Deen you know
he goes guys wait a minute this old
white lady used the n-word once 30 years
ago and she's ruined and just like they
should build statues to her this is the
least racist white woman in the South
it's literally the same thing by the way
is back now on YouTube oh she's back
making under the radar making the
cooking shows or whatever prepared to
her she clearly felt very bad about
saying this one word once uh many years
in the past Scott Adams uh you know
locals one of the first people you
recruit on locals yeah uh he got kicked
off uh his publisher said we're not
doing a book with you as you know yeah
he's like all right he's gonna do he
decided to do what I did just publish
directly with Amazon Amazon gave him a
lifetime ban wow without a reason he
went public he well he's like
uh they reversed their decision and now
that he is producing the book through
Amazon on uh his next book which would
have been published to a major publisher
and the point being
take when someone says things are
getting better that doesn't mean they're
good but it's good that things get
better usually so the fact is that they
weren't able to completely eviscerate
Scott Adams who said things that are
objectively more inflammatory than what
Paula Dean said one word once they're
sure well Scott likes to poke there I
think he's a great guy and I agree with
most of his stuff for sure but he is a
point being he wasn't he's still on
Twitter good never that never stopped
he's still on locals he's still on on
YouTube I believe I'm almost certain and
his book is coming out so that is one
example of where they went for him he
gave him somewhat plenty of ammunition
and he has not been read out of polite
Society although you know all of Dilbert
got kicked off its entire syndication is
that right like a year ago so all of the
you know I don't know how many hundreds
or thousands of newspapers that were
syndicating Dilbert kicked him off he
runs them all in locals now I mean how
cool that in this fight that you and I
have been doing in this crazy YouTube
thing that we've been doing for years I
created this tech company that
eventually merged with this tech company
that we're sitting in the booth outside
the debate defending all of the uh
because Linda Vicara what's her last
name Oh Linda Linda Vaccaro it's August
10th uh Phoenix is telling yeah
something happened with Twitter so she
they basically you know Elon very
famously said he's a free speech
absolutist yeah so their new policy on
um on Twitter was yakarino I'm sorry
yeah no no she he said their new
approach is to dmpl amplify posts that
are lawful but awful and I'm gonna steal
them I'm going to steal man her position
okay because if you are trying to get
advertisers right yeah and as soon as
someone who's gay who's a minority who's
a woman who's Jewish
you post something and you're just
getting slurs and denunciations why am I
going to be setting up my shingle here
and being the target of personal abuse
that's that's kind of The Balancing Act
you're gonna have to play so her whole
point is okay we're not going to be
banning them the problem is who watches
the Watchers right like we've been
through this listen here's the other
thing you can't be a free speech
absolutist unless you're gonna use
circle of reasoning because we all agree
that like Dave Rubin I'm gonna kill you
is not acceptable no of course
pornography is not acceptable their
doxing is probably for most people it's
not acceptable you're gonna have to draw
a line somewhere yeah so the question is
where do you draw the line where is it
her can you is it okay to use a slur
it's like the talmud can you use a slur
but not a slur against the individ
target against the individual so I'm
sure my preference so so when people say
Free Speech absolutist my preference
would be within the conflict confines of
the law of the United States which has
done a pretty damn good job on this
because of the First Amendment so I
actually believe in libel and slander
laws and I believe that you you can't
openly threaten somebody and you can't
yell fire in a crowd theater with the
intent to do harm you can yell fire in a
crowded theater it's about intent
um if you can't yell anything in any
theater because it's a private property
that's also a difference they yell in a
theater right right so that's why with
the intend to do are but the point is I
would prefer when you watch there's no
before social media came around if you
were if it's 1987 and you were watching
The Cosby Show where you were watching
American Gladiators and a commercial for
tide or a commercial for Mercedes-Benz
came on no one thought that had
something to do with endorsing The Cosby
Show or American Gladiators we've done
this very weird thing in social media
where someone thinks because a pre-roll
ad plays before one of my videos it has
something to do with me sure or
something like that and that that
psychological shift that everyone's
endorsing everything as opposed to a
company wants to just sell their
freaking pans no but or they just want
to sell their products
they want to have a prominent celebrity
on their platform which they do yeah and
that celebrity is going to be the
subject of slurs and abuse and all this
kind of hateful stuff it's going to be
hard to draw the names that you want and
that's something they have to we're
worried about it sure there's there's a
yeah there's an Optics issue there look
and there's a difference between being a
business that wants the profit and also
being like right a utility and all of
that
um
ah well we'll see I guess but you know
that doesn't surprise me because when
Elon took over remember he said I
believe in freedom of speech not freedom
of reach wasn't that his line so that in
essence is what he's saying the problem
with that again is the who watches the
Watchers thing so like you could say
okay we will guard against a certain
amount of
hate whatever that is with the good
intentions but where does good
intentions where does that road I know
it's necessarily good intentions so much
as our self-interest yeah you know it's
they're like look this is a company
we're here you know we're hemorrhaging
money uh you know once the advertisers
leave this is a big we can't turn the
lights on and I'm sure you've had to
deal with this issue with the locals and
Rumble as well yeah and that's why
Rumble which I'm again we're at the
rumble Studio here which is awesome
Rumble is the exclusive live streamer
tonight it's not on YouTube the debate
it's on Rumble it's so awesome that we
were able to build all this you know
Rumble is running its own cloud like
we're building the separate Internet
it's really what we're doing you I mean
you said Scott Adams was one of the
first guys I think the first three guys
I called I think it was you uh Scott
Adams and Bridget fantasy were the three
that really helped me launch this entire
thing so it's pretty cool I think
Phoenix is saying to get to something on
the second on all on August 2nd I guess
there was something we missed and then
we're pretty much close close to rapping
holy cow
what did we you want to tell him what it
was what was it
oh no we did that we did that I want him
my guys go off the green too they go off
the grid when I come back that's a weird
thing
it was a separation I know what I'm
doing good Lord who do you think I am
Glenn Beck I know my job I'm no screw up
don't don't you're not done yet because
we've got a few minutes because I wanna
let's go through these eight names oh
okay yeah you should do something and
you know you know let's talk about what
we think their opportunity strengths so
on and so forth so I'm gonna go from
like the lowest this is probably the
best uh bergram the whatever his name is
from North Dakota he blow out his knee
like it's probably the knee right let's
suppose he didn't blow out the knee I I
truly don't know who he is it is utterly
irrelevant and let's not even waste you
know what I bet that he's gonna come in
with some canned lines that he's gonna
deliver awfully and it's just gonna just
be cringe as F all right ASA Hutchinson
is going to be gunning very heavily for
president Trump yeah
um do you think he's in a position to
make any sort of noise what's his Lane
no there's no Lane there's no Lane
there's nobody there's nothing okay got
it we got some protesters out here now
okay uh Tim Scott
I think Tim Scott look I I've had him on
the show I I like him I think he's been
a good Senator and I think he represents
a lot of the right ideas and they're
changing the USA maybe for us it's funny
we've got the people can't see it right
now we'll take some pictures but the
DeSantis bus 2024 is right there and
then there's some Pro trumpets that's
not the the status bus that's Chris
Christie
he's good he's good uh the uh there's
some Trump people right here so it's
it's starting to percolate around here
uh
but wait sorry Tim Scott no I think
he'll say some nice things and I think
it'll be sort of like people won't
really want to attack him and I think
he'll do just fine tonight but he'll do
just fine but that's not good enough no
it won't it doesn't long term it doesn't
long term get you there but I think it's
it's some of the right ideas and he has
a nice way about him and I think uh uh
Nikki Haley's gonna be the only woman on
that stage that's an opportunity for her
uh she's obviously Gonna Stand Out look
the truth is as much as the bass seems
the Trump base seems to hate Nikki Nikki
was at the UN under Trump got us out of
all of these Accords she was we didn't
get into Wars when she was uh you know
our U.N Ambassador uh I think she's
extreme she's just like a pro and she
was an extremely good governor of South
Carolina so even though I do I fully
disagree with her or let's say 80
disagree with her on Ukraine which is
obviously a big issue I think she's just
gonna come off as pretty good maybe a
little scripted and a little whatever
but I think she's gonna be like people
remember those women that you're talking
about that maybe could shift a little
bit this time or think Biden's
ridiculous or the Democrat or nuts or
they've had it with the wokes it's like
she's the type of person they could be
like all right I actually I think she's
gonna try to be a soccer mom kind of
that hockey mom kind of Sarah Palin
earlier yeah and that might be a good
look for her but I don't see how much is
get her in terms of traction uh let's
talk about Mike Pence who I I think he's
I just don't know where the lane is I
don't see the lane I think he's going to
be setting himself up to look like an
idiot he's he was I'm gonna take back
what I just said because he did far
better in the 2020 debates than Trump
did he nuked Kamala Harris he was calm
he was superb you know what I take back
I think Mike Pence is going to be the
sleeper candidate solely because he did
so well in 2020. interesting interesting
I mean he was particularly good at that
it was one you know he has this weird
thing where he doesn't look at sometimes
at the person he's talking to remember
the Tucker thing a couple of weeks ago
and Tucker was really kind of crushing
him and he refused to look at him I just
don't see where it is at with him but
but before we get to the other guys
isn't it interesting so these seven
people that we're mentioning now or
these eight these eight people that
we're mentioning think about how much
fundamentally better they are than what
the Democrats threw out last time like
whether you like all these people or not
or disagree with them on foreign policy
or any of this stuff like these are
functioning people right like no I guess
I accept that I accept that but like
just in terms of weekends too belief in
reality and all that we're going to
bring food not terrible good yeah
um Chris Christie we both agreed or we
talked about earlier that he might
surprise us tonight he's gonna come out
swinging on everybody yeah uh Vivek I
think is going to be very well prepped
yep he knows the knives are out yeah uh
he's I don't know how prepared he's
going to be and I don't know what
they're going to hit him with he's
clearly going to be you think someone's
going to go after him it's going to be
interesting to see who they go after
tonight
this is on the down client doesn't
Trump's already done the damage there so
why would everyone go after DeSantis but
so they might be going after vague as
the Trump proxy there's something there
do they go after Trump if he's not even
on stage it's going to be interesting
tonight the question here's the the
elephant in the room man I don't mean
again Chris Christie or the Republican
mascot the the moderators are they going
to have this be a trump-centric debate
yeah are they going to acknowledge he's
not there and stick to the issues
wouldn't it be nice if it wasn't like
putting aside what do you think about
Trump or anything like if they really
were just like here like could we do one
debate that's not circus we'll get to
Circus it's an election Brett right it's
Martha and Brett look at those giant
heads right there they're both very
professional I don't think they're going
to make it Trump trump I think they're
really going to stick to the issues I
think that's what people want more than
anything else I know we all behave
differently online and Twitter and all
that stuff but I really think people are
just like boy wouldn't it be nice if we
could just return to something that was
roughly decent you know just like a
roughly approximate ballpark give me
something and and DeSantis is obviously
the front runner of the people on stage
um and that's the question are they
going to be going after him right it'll
be an interesting play for him it's like
is he going to go after Trump while
Trump's not there and does that actually
accomplish anything you know like does
that again that unmovable base so you go
after Trump and even if you say
something that's true you could say for
example this is 100 True Trump ran
re-election ads all about fauci praising
him that is true we have played it on my
show and that it was Trump you know
Trump 2020. how much he loves fauci and
how fauci loves him
you could say that up there and and you
you might get someone to be like oh
that's interesting but but that
unmovable base doesn't seem to care
right so that's I think what they're
running up against and I don't know what
you do with that I don't know in a way
this is going to be like a blondie
concert without Debbie Harry right if
Trump's not there and he's obviously the
former president and obviously Biden's
win was in some ways a referendum on the
Trump uh presidency like what do you do
and you CA it's really hard for you as
let's suppose Senator Tim Scott to be
like when I'm president it's like you've
got two huge obstacles which is the
entire Democratic media apparatus and
you've got the Trump campaign to go
through so you know there's kind of this
phoniness about it if you're just gonna
pretend that we don't have to talk about
Trump it's a lot of fun we said it
before but kfabe it's like we sometimes
it's just like we're in the show it's a
show or in the show what's next season
what keeps us watching you know maybe
we're at the stage of democracy where
the machine so doesn't work for any of
us anymore that the importance is The
Show Must Go On because if the show
didn't go on then people would seriously
be like oh and here's the other
thing no matter what happens tonight
whoever gets the sound bites they're
gonna have to deliver rehearse lines
Trump's getting arrested tomorrow so in
a way today's Wednesday it's supposedly
happening tomorrow so in a way this
debate is almost Superfluous because
let's suppose with vacation out of the
park he's got these great one-liners
he's got bde everyone loves it but
tomorrow it's like here's the mug shot
possibly of the former president at
everyone immediately on Twitter is going
to make that their profile pic every
left kind of live on earth so we're
gonna see what happens there Matt let's
I just want to thank you you did an
absolutely bang-up job and it's
extremely hot right here in Atlanta
right now you are keeping your cool I
got a little yeah I run hot um but I'm
thrilled that you uh that you came and
did this and then I will talk to the
camera for a second because I'm a
professional broadcaster and tonight
immediately after the debate so we're
going to be inside of the debate but
immediately after we'll walk out of
there about 10 minutes early we'll be
back here I will be broadcasting you to
join me I'm invited I told him to invite
you they didn't invite me
well maybe malice will be hanging out
somewhere else we'll see what happens uh
but uh we're in touch with desantis's
campaign and Nikki and I just texted
Larry now that I know he's here and uh
oh and vivec and and the rest of them
the rest of them uh I guess not Trump uh
and we'll see how many join us and we'll
talk about the show that must go on I'll
be here
thank you guys for watching it's good to
be back oh and uh one other thing we are
rebuilding our studio right now it's in
the midst of the rebuild I cannot wait
to show it to you the official Reuben
report the real show will be back on
September 5th we need a little time to
just put the rest of the pieces uh
together so I may do like a semi-dip Off
the Grid till then but we'll be busy in
the studio and all that we'll keep you
posted on social media I thank you for
watching it's good to be back let's get
something to drink yeah okay